Okay, so many of you are aware that it is
not just cognitive decline.
That is a possibility to explain Donald Trump's
bizarre behavior, but increasingly the explanation
we are seeing get more and more traction is
amphetamine use or better said abuse.
We've seen Trump's upper and downer modes.
Two very different trumps depending on uh,
what's going on and we don't know exactly
what's going on.
Sometimes high energy, sweaty red, agitated
speaking, quickly corresponding with the upper
phase and then the slow slurring, depressed
Trump who often has trouble making sense of
the speech that's on his prompter or on paper
in front of him, which corresponds with more
of a coming down from uppers phase.
We've also seen pictures of Donald Trump's
Trump tower desk stuffed with boxes of Sudafed
and specifically a version of Sudafed that's
not sold in the United States.
And it is more Sudafed than one person can
even legally buy at a time in the United States.
Now, Sudafed can be crushed up and snorted
like Adderall can.
It can be taken by mouth publicly.
Trump often show signs and symptoms of amphetamine
abuse.
Some examples include sounding stuffed up
whenever he's in downer mode.
Has Donald Trump had a cold for the last three
years.
I guess it's possible, but it is common that
a Sudafed for example, is a nasal decongestant.
It can cause a rebound congestion effect where
it wears off, especially when you're taking
recreational amounts.
As we see that Donald Trump does this often
and constantly sounds a stuffed up, Trump
in fact sounded stuffed up during the press
conference with Turkish president Airto on
last week and I'm going to get to that momentarily.
Another effect of that rebound congestion
after you start coming down from the uppers
is that you sniff a lot, which Donald Trump
does all the time.
As you may have seen compilation videos of
Trump speaking and, and sniffing below, uh,
between, uh, phrases as I am sort of demonstrating
for you right now.
Uh, Trump also appearing to have trouble speaking
when in downer mode.
Sometimes it seems as though his dentures
are loose.
But remember, based on his medical exam, Trump
doesn't wear dentures.
Rich guys tend not to wear dentures, but to
get medic, uh, dental implants.
So that's not an explanation.
It just so happens though that dry mouth is
a symptom of amphetamine abuse, be it Adderall
or Sudafed.
This is what it sounds like when Trump is
in that mode.
Let us rethink all the assumptions and open
our hearts and minds to possible and possibilities.
And finally I asked the leaders of the region
political and religious, Israeli and Palestinian,
Jewish and Christian and Muslim to join us
in the noble quest for the lasting peace.
Thank you.
God bless you.
God bless Israel.
God bless the Palestinians and God bless the
United church.
Thank you very much.
There it is.
And again, if you don't believe Trump wears
dentures, which we've been told he doesn't
enrich, people tend not to wear them.
Dry mouth makes a lot more sense and it just
so happens that it's another symptom of methamphetamine
or of amphetamine abuse.
So that's all the stuff we knew.
The new thing is that I was contacted by an
anesthesiologist over the weekend who said,
David, I was looking at pictures and video
of Donald Trump at last week's press conference
with the Turkish president, Erdogan.
There were bright lights on them.
It was a very brightly lit room and in a normal
situation, pupils would be relatively contracted
during that situation, but Donald Trump has
extremely dilated pupils.
When you look closely at him from this press
conference.
Now of course in a bright room, pupils should
contract if something is not keeping them
dilated.
As we know, stimulants increase the concentration
of norepinephrine in the brain, which keeps
the pupils stuck in that open position and
anesthesiologist looked at this and wrote
to me, when I see this, I see someone who
is clearly on some kind of stimulant.
Now you also saw Trump blinking a lot and
squinting, which would be exactly what you
do if you're in a bright room and your pupils
aren't contracting.
When you go to the eye doctor, as I recently
did, and you get the drops to dilate your
pupils so that the doctor can look in at the
back of the eye when you get out and go outside.
If you're not wearing very dark sunglasses,
it is extremely uncomfortable.
So do we know for sure we don't, but it's
all shaping up pretty clearly.
I want to hear from you.
The slurred speech, dry mouth, dilated pupils,
upper downer, Trump sniffing and congestion,
another known rebound effect of using a too
much a nasal decongestant.
Let me know what you think I want to hear
from you.
Send me [inaudible]
tweet on Twitter at the Pacman.
Leave a reply to the YouTube clip or the Facebook
video clip.
Wherever you are watching.
I want to hear from you.
What
do
you think is
going
on